wenn das meer vor den weißen stränden
sansibar es geht dann kommen sie die
singen den seetang bäuerinnen was sie
bei ernten ist weltweit begehrt und
teuer der seetang ist unser einziges
einkommen von dem all unsere familie
leben
umgerechnet ein paar cent für das was in
europa lifestyle und luxus gegen falten
ist im einsatz an der alge lerne ich wie
die frauen trotz armut in würde ihre
ernte tragen
[Musik]
den anfang hier im weg macht die
höflichkeit crashkurs bei heli mit
aminati chef in baden wie geht's gut
dann bindet mir amina meine
arbeitskleidung um 29 frauen warten
schon ungeduldig auf meine muskeln jede
erklärt mir was aufregung schon bevor
die algenzucht beginnt ein job den hier
im muslimischen sansibar fast nur frauen
machen unsere männer haben sich daran
gewöhnt dass wir arbeiten haben wir
verbessern das einkommen und damit gehe
ich jetzt eigenanbau erst einmal
warmsingen unter anleitung von nur
sucher und dann beginnt die stundenlange
arbeit im knietiefen wasser das stetig
steigt die meisten frauen haben nie
schwimmen gelernt sehr alten haben keine
wurzeln sie wachsen an unseren strippen
und werden alle paar tage abgetrennt und
an anderen stücken weiter geknüpft um
weiter zu wachsen
die frauen sind eine gemeinschaft und
teilen alles auf ihren feldern auch den
verdienst doch vom weltweiten boom
bleibt ihnen kaum etwas was habt ihr
davon dass ihr in einer gruppe arbeitet
wir arbeiten hier alle in einer gruppe
weil wir so mehr erreichen können und
vielleicht mehr unterstützung bekommen
allein ist das noch schwieriger und wenn
uns jemand unterstützt dann müssen wir
doch organisiert sein
sechs wochen dauert es bis zur ernte
dann haben die büschel ihr gewicht
verzehnfacht habe lernte
so sieht die ernte aus
die ich jetzt mit nur surer in den
salzstock
[Musik]
sansibar eine inselgruppe vor der
ostküste afrikas 1,3 millionen menschen
leben hier allein 23.000 sind algen
bauern 90 prozent davon frauen
getrockneter seetang der als sehr gesund
gilt ist vor allem als grundlage für
seifen cremes medikamente und super foot
gefragt die abnehmer sind in asien
europa und den usa dort angekommen hat
sich der preis war vielfach eine algen
haltige antifaltencreme kostet gern mal
70 euro
der 30 kilo transport in die welt
beginnt heute auf meinem kopf und mit
nur sowas selbstverständnis einfach
nicht immerhin mit einer ahnung
suzuka ist 44 und ernährt mit den algen
vier kinder
kraft gebe ihr und den anderen die kraft
der alge das macht richtig stark auch in
den venen
ich weiß dass die algen sehr teuer in
europa sind es ist einfach schade dass
wir nur so wenig daran verdienen drei
tage später dass sie großes trocken der
kopf wackelt immer noch ursula und ich
liefern die ware beim händler ab zwölf
kilo auf meinem kopf ursula schafft
locker 50 kilogramm auf dem kopf
[Musik]
erwischt hin oder her die rechnung muss
stimmen meine zwölf kilogramm bringen
umgerechnet magere drei euro fünfzig
geteilt durch 29
wenn die frauen mir das verkauft haben
kommt es zum großmarkt und danach wird
das nach dänemark verschifft dort machen
sie daraus lebensmittel medizin und
viele andere sachen für nur sucher und
die anderen frauen endete sie algen
verdienst an seiner kasse in einem der
ärmsten länder der welt geht der gewinn
ins ausland das durchschnittseinkommen
auf sansibar liegt pro monat bei
umgerechnet rund 20 us dollar
im nachbardorf sind diese frauen einen
schritt weiter und produzieren selbst
dank schredder maschine stecken sie
jetzt mitten in der seifenherstellung
aus dem geschredderten alpen pulver und
dieser öl brühe rühren streichen und
schneiden sie duft und gewürze
alles handarbeit die seifen verkaufen
die frauen in der gegend so bleibt das
ganze geld hier zuerst legen wir das
geld beiseite für unsere produktion hier
wenn mal was ist und den rest teilen wir
unter uns allen auf damit kann dann
jeder von uns selbst entscheiden was
ihre familie am dringendsten benötigt
die küste sansibars für die ernte frauen
von weesow sichert sie das überleben
neuerdings auch mit badekappe vier von
ihnen haben endlich schwimmen gelernt
das was frauen auf sansibar nie können
mussten und doch immer wollten um die
wellen des ozeans angstfrei zu erleben
[Musik]